I rode shotgun in a lead humvee
And I looked for bombs.
Stop the truck
You don't see the bomb unless they want you to.
What you got?
Yo I don't see nothing man
You don't see it, he feels it.
I was a good soldier
I had purpose, and I loved it
You kick some ass over there?
Yeah, yeah man
We wanted it to be perfect
I'm home with my favorite girls, it's perfect baby.
-Am I getting laid or what?
Oh yeah, you're getting laid.
How long you been up?
It's already 4 PM in Baghdad
One chocolate chip smiley face pancake for ya
She doesn't like chocolate
Ok guess I missed that.
Therapist:Two army commendations, an army achievement medal, impressive.
Wife:You never told me you were a hero. Don't spare me the details, I can take anything but quiet.
You are my hammer out there don't let these young guys see you fold.
I don't belong here.
He did his job, now do yours.
-You alright? -No I'm not alright.
Can't name him after me. He's too perfect.
Is there a specific incident that troubles you?
I now this don't look like much of a life. But every morning I get up I'm grateful. I'm alive because of you.
Woman: Thank you for looking after my son.
I'm not a hero, we're brothers we look after each other.